hi there Rob Han Laurie here standing in
for reviewer Miguel concepción excelling
in sport means knowing when you are in
arms and control in rocket League both
events occur countless times in any
given match not surprising for a game
inspired by soccer it caters to the
realist to thrills and having sole
control of the ball for a few seconds
despite knowing it can be snatched at
any time the best part is that you get
to kill opponents dreams from the
comfort of a very very fast car
every moment in rocket League demands
split-second judgment and the game
thrives on speed and momentum this is
best exemplified by the gravity defying
excitement of driving up the side of any
of the game's arenas this ability is
useful as well as thrilling without the
curves along the edges of the pitch cars
would simply bang into the wall instead
your tires smoothly caress these bends
as you ride the walls horizontally
chasing the ball in parallel with the
rest of the cars on the pitch the ball
is comparable to that perpetually
bouncing beach ball you find at every
music festival only slightly less
buoyant it bounces and flies and
unpredictable directions when touched by
two parties at the same time this is
where fortune favors the rocket League
sports person who embraces chaos
transcendence comes when you realize you
don't have to be in control of the ball
at all times
you should chase it only when you think
you can make a difference
the ball explodes on a goal scored with
a literal bang it's a colorful smoke
filled explosion that sends all cars
flying away at Heights so spectacular
you can't help but savor the blast
rocket league is that rare kind of game
where you're compelled to play your best
even when you're being blown out and
there's only a minute left on the clock
drop in drop out online play means you
rarely wait to get in on the action and
can apply tactical thinking against
human opponents tactical thinking in
turn leads to performing with finesse
you cannot open car doors to use them
like arms instead you can spin your car
forwards backwards and sideways which is
analogous to bicycle kicks and headers
you use these moves to advance the ball
and soon learn how to ricochet shots on
goal
it's all obvious highlight-reel material
which is why the replay save option is
such a great touch learning and
mastering these advanced moves makes
playing rocket League phenomenally
absorbing match after match after match
playing a single player session in
rookie mode is as useful a practice
ground as the training mode itself
without real-life competitors ruthlessly
charging to the center of the field for
the ball drop you can practice making
spectacular goals from midfield the
drawback is an imperfect AI of course
the true value here is in the
competition rocket League wisely avoid
silly RPG s con locks and other gimmicks
all the arena's are uniform and
consistent in shape without any bells
and whistles like the terraces and its
predecessor supersonic acrobatic rocket
powered battle cars the only variables
are the team sizes ai difficulty and
season lengths the joy of rocket League
rests on the countless plans that are
conceived and discarded every other
second and any given match trying to
predict where and how the ball will
bounce next is a game within the game
despite the use of cars rocket League
emulates the emotional surge is typical
of the beautiful game such as the rush
of an unexpected fast break with rocket
League the promising concept of
combining two wonderful things cars and
soccer is equally magnificent in
execution